[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting a we're
actually doing a podcast I hurt but I
did here we did a podcast last week oh I
did a little more of it than you did I
heard I didn't listen I don't listen I
don't I'm not at your biscuit ear I just
make the ear bit well we and goes into
our ears we listen to it like through
these headphones while we're doing but
yeah but listen to it late
once-in-a-lifetime experience so far for
me was an air biscuit happening and I
was at president for it I heard lots of
good positive things about your
performance I don't know what you said
what you did but I heard good things
about it so congratulations on that I've
heard I've heard positive feedback I
appreciate that I was just reading a few
hours ago that they know some a few
mythical beasts said they know what it
would be like to have a podcast with
just me and they would be okay with that
how many minutes would be okay how many
minutes did you go it kind of faded off
to where I forgot they were there and I
was just talking to myself like I do
around the house single-digit minutes
yeah it might end up you know between
the ad read and then at the very end
which kind of trailed off I'd say about
30 minutes no way okay so you know what
an eight minute podcast would just link
would be like which I don't know are you
threatened that could be what the future
is all about are you threatened or you
know what I could walk out of this one
early I got things I could do I got
litigation I could try to sidestep yeah
but I could write you drove me here so
that's true yeah so you'd have to figure
out a ride home I do want to hear about
the update because you really left us
hanging like you literally ditched us in
the middle of great that was great your
ear biscuit great production I leave you
guys hanging you had to come back and
hear the rest of the story lots of
unanswered questions so I do want to get
into that we have not taken the time to
fully process our vacations that we had
separately
and we need to do that as friends and as
and for for you your biscuit ear you
need the update on how our vacations
went we each had an entire week apart
from each other over the Thanksgiving
week few weeks back and you went to
Hawaii and I went to Mexico and we
haven't fully downloaded that so do that
I want to get into all that
and because the operative question is
who made the right choice because last
year we both went to Hawaii together and
it was the question was did we make the
right choice together and we did we made
a good well we can get into that yeah
we'll talk about that in a second but
let's see so where did we leave off with
the leaving to go meet I was leaving to
go meet your name your neighbor and even
as you were going out like the details
of how you were meeting started to
stress me out you know you were meeting
at a public place in order to smooth
over your relationship so that he would
not litigate no that wasn't I mean my
motivation and meaning was to get was to
establish a neighborly relationship
which you know but he also threatened to
sue his lawyer the net effect of that
well I didn't threaten to sue me they
said it would take they would do
everything they would do everything
possible you know there was no there it
was just it was a threat it was a little
bit of a threatening letter when the
lawyer gets involved yes it's
threatening yeah lawyers just don't send
letters in order to just you know to
just talk to somebody so let me tell you
what happened if they're lonely or
something I originally was going to meet
my wife there and meet him there and
that was that was complicating but as I
got close to where we were gonna be
meeting which is relatively near my
house I was like I have like eight
minutes to get to my house and get back
to this place and so I called Jesse and
I was like hey I'm coming all the way to
the house I'm gonna pick you up and
let's just go so we can be get there
together because it's one less variable
you take
Shepard that was okay and you decided
not to take a child and that was in a
decision that I made it was that someone
was already watching Shepard your
neighbor had been watching one of the
one of the ladies who watches our kids
from time to time was watching him
already and so she just kept watching
him and say like hey Shepard why don't
you stay at home and just start throwing
garden refuse into our neighbor's yard
while we're nobody was sort of been
counterproductive so I picked Jessie up
and we get there and Mike and this was
my first concern this is where we left
off it's like when you get there I'm not
a nun of
none of your concerns came to fruition
because when I got there I was getting
out of the car and he and his wife and
his kids who are like high school-aged
we're all getting out of the car that's
my worst fear for you was that you were
gonna move you were gonna have a
pre-meeting because I said you don't
want to meet in line but see I think the
thing that you don't understand is it
yeah get into business once a person has
made the decision to have a quote
unquote friendly meeting with you
because the you know the pretense here
is that we're gonna meet at a coffee
shop this is not confrontational this is
a scheduled thing that you weren't
meeting at a dojo right and so as soon
as I saw him get out of actually III met
his kids first and was like hello
introduce myself and then Jesse meets
the wife and then he gets out of the car
and it was all just it was right from
the beginning it was all smiles
everybody was everybody was like which
is weird well I know I mean I don't
think I think I think that's part of the
dynamic I think the dynamic is there was
a heated exchange that escalated very
quickly and now that we've all had time
to think about it and there's been a
meeting that has been requested I think
everyone has emotionally prepared for
this moment well yeah
maybe I can understand there's not as
much drama as you want there to be
bottom line you want there to be drama
for the sake of entertainment I'm
telling you that there it was it would
there was no drama it was just like well
hold on to me this is dramatic the fact
that there was such that the
first thing that happened was it was
like two old friends meeting so I give
credit to your letter for having a
disarming element I mean because all
intention the last thing you heard from
him was that he was on the spectrum of
happiness and unhappiness he was leaning
towards the latter I mean so to show up
and you know be hey we're friends is a
little premature that's the point of the
meaning but I guess your letter was so
disarming I'm not saying that we're
friends I'm just saying that it is not
unusual for two people who are
negotiating something that is even
heated to once they set a think about to
world leaders right think about to world
leaders whose countries are fighting
yeah they agree to a meeting do you walk
into the meeting with guns ablaze and
know that give me an example of that
happening it doesn't happen when - they
meet and there's pleasantries well you
the meetings begin with pleasantries I
guess it was no different unless this is
the second meeting and the first one was
guns blazing from the moment that yeah
but that wasn't a meeting that was an
altercation there's a difference yeah
well it was an unplanned altercation so
it was a planned so is a summit of sorts
in your analogy I'm a little I'm a
little surprised because it was like it
was two countries who were in like a
battle a war but let's say a skirmish
but there's one country where skirmish
mean who does not feel that this is a
skirmish or a battle one cook one
country that feels that this is just a
misunderstanding and we will soon get to
a peace we will return to peace so
you're telling me that you got in line
together well not only that there was a
scramble for who was going to pay for
all the beverages I got my credit card
out he's got his cash out he actually
beat me to it
we were both trying to pay for each
other that's how friendly it was right
from the get-go I think you're you guys
are both overcompensating no you're
missing again I expected all this I knew
that he was gonna want to pay and I was
gonna want to pay I went in knowing that
this is how most humans behave but he
really got his cash in there because the
cash you know I don't know if the cat
dollars are bigger than credit cards I
don't know what it was there was also
know a couple of interesting things so
you knew it
this point that the tree was staying
there nothing was changed you're like
alright this is over my weren't even
started I knew that the day that I was
sitting there arguing with him that this
was gonna be the outcome
I mean I honestly I did I just didn't
know how I was gonna get did you know
you're gonna get a free tea out of it no
that was a nun exactly that's nice a
couple of things too if you've been
following this story that are
interesting they'll come down your chin
first thing is that they had no I just
was me just being egotistical because
they had absolutely no idea who I was
kids had no idea wife had no idea he had
no idea so the whole thing that he said
about you think you're a special person
or whatever was just me reading into
into into the fact that I'm somewhat
well-known on the Internet who's the bad
guy now so that was just me being a jerk
you know and assuming assuming things
it's like one of the it's like when
somebody comes up and says excuse me and
I think oh well you want a picture with
me right and really they just want bleh
borrow you know a pencil or something
this is a plot twist in the whole story
I think I think what we're all
experiencing right now is that he was
the good guy all alone well okay well
let me keep telling the story now the
second piece of information is that the
person take the barista if you will it's
not exactly a coffee shop but we'll call
her a barista because we ordered tea and
coffees she was a fan so that was a bit
awkward Oh cuz he's paying for you and
she and then she asked him for us you
know she's like I love you I love the
show can I get a picture with you which
this is this is completely out he he
didn't know how to take this right
because he thought that she wanted a
picture with him at first he was like
what would picture what and then really
it was like I you know that was an
awkward situation but of course I was
nice I took the picture and they're like
get my neighbor in here we're all right
we're good friends so then his kids
actually stayed in the car they were
there because they had to be taken to
tutoring or something like that so it
was what it was was me and Jesse and and
him and his wife sitting across from
each other in the way that they stay
sacktual ii sat down at a four-person
table they set across from each other
which then meant that i sat next to him
and she sat next my wife sat next to his
wife
so already it was just like men on one
side women we weren't even there was no
confrontational posturing you understand
what I'm saying you were there was no
battle line drawn I was sitting next to
him actually touched him several times
during the conversation like reached out
and touched him or grazed him like this
like like a shoulder touch you know
seriously totally serious
that's how I can't that's how I got I
can't believe you because I can't I
can't talk sure I've never seen you
you've never seen me in this in
peacemaking mode yeah I don't you grab
dish I didn't grab it I just touched him
gently like this you you rested your
hand on his shoulder yeah if I was there
I would I would have just felt horrible
you've what you've never seen me work
like this before yeah this is a
different mode this is like waking up
from anesthesia red or something now but
let me I don't I don't wanted this get
to long because I want to talk about her
vacations let me just some basically
what ended up happening was how long did
you talk to him before you even got to
fighting we spent five to seven minutes
just catching up and finding out where
their kids went to school where our kids
went to school and how long they've been
at the house and that kind of thing like
you were just meeting neighbors for the
first I feel threatened in our level of
friendship now it's like he's he gonna
replace me no that's probably not gonna
happen
but very quickly we did get to the issue
at hand and how was that transition I I
started it I said listen I'm glad you
guys are willing to get together and
talk to us and I you know I think we
basically just got this whole thing this
whole relationship started off on the
wrong foot is that when you touched it I
don't know then out of that moment
that's too early I waited about 15
minutes in before the touching started
when that happens tell me and then I
said first of all I want to apologize
again about the situation with the the
not the tree in question but the tree
that started the bush and he called it
Bush called a tree which what what have
you I think he probably considers it a
tree I'm sorry about the limbs that were
cut without asking and then the
placement of the refuse in your yard
without asking although it was temporary
in my mind the entire time you let with
an apology and then he powerful he
countered with an apology he's like you
no I'm sorry about the way I reacted
this is a paraphrasing I'm sorry about
the way I reacted you caught me at a bad
time
I was just sitting down there looking at
the refuse in the yard getting mad about
it and then you walked right down the
driveway and it was just like you seed
out right in a perfect just perfect
storm and I'm a pilot I apologize for
the things that I said and you were you
were getting in like a black SUV which
might be misconstrued as a limo yeah it
was and that's why he's like it was a
pretentious like it was a little
pretentious yeah that's why it seemed
like a special person I guess it was
just a black SUV but then he did go on
to inform me that do you both apologize
great great move by truthfully from a
legal standpoint if now that there's a
tree in his yard that I planted and
there's lighting and sprinklers that are
going to the tree it could be I could
have a legal case I don't know exactly
even though my dad teaches the subject
property or did it at one point there it
might be eminent domain or something
like that I don't know what it is but
basically if you're treating a portion
of someone else's yard as your yard for
a certain amount of time and no one says
anything about it it could be the case
that now that's basically your yard and
so he's like I don't want there to be
any permitting I don't want the
boundaries between our yards to be
construed if I try to sell the house you
try to sell the house or whatever so
what I would like is a letter from you
that says that you are giving me the
tree giving me the tree the giving tree
shel silverstein are you sold on are you
telling me that the the okay and then
you said what I said I would gladly give
you the tree you were going to give him
the tree that this whole fight is over
the whole thing that was like this tree
is the center of the entire conflict is
now a gift to him yet Lincoln you don't
understand how well this is this is so
poetic he now owns the tree it is a gift
it is a peace offering to him but it's
exactly in the same place because it's a
freaking tree and I have gifted him the
tree legally I'll also say I'd like to
give it to you by chopping it down and
throwing it across and I have also any
four out I have also stated
in this letter that the lighting and the
sprinklers are temporary and can be
removed at his discretion and it does
not constitute a Miss a construe in sub
the current property boundary so you've
written a letter and already sent it
yeah and you using words like screw it I
don't think I used that word cuz I'm not
sure it's a word I just made it up on
the spot now but I did use the word
constitute you know I think I said
constitute a departure from the
currently legally established boundaries
between our properties boundaries
blurred lines did you you know that's
ironic you know the song blurred lines
I'm for the year was the subject of a
long and and an aggressive litigation
and that's not what's happening so yeah
I I I wrote that letter just a couple of
days after our meeting I sent it through
his lawyer to him could have just hung
it on his tree no completely legal I
wanted like an ornament legal and now I
have what has happened here is that
everyone's happy I have gifted I you
know I've never given anyone a tree this
is the first time maybe the last time
I've given you you've given me like a
whole herd of tree and you know it and
more like a redwood patch
yeah and now the idea that he feels like
one one-hundredth as good as I felt when
you gave me these trees just warms my
heart and I think they were well on our
way to having a great relationship we
should bring him in here it's okay well
you know I'll talk to him about that
that's a possibility send him another
letter through his lawyer it's called a
summon when now he summons him to the
plow we've got each other's numbers
we've talked about how we're gonna look
out for each other's properties when
we're out of town I feel like we've
actually this has gotten into a great
place and Wow
and you know I told you from the
beginning as soon as this happened and I
knew that it was just misunderstanding
I just couldn't live with the fact that
I was in this kind of dispute it makes
me uncomfortable and I wanted two things
to happen a I wanted to not to do
anything about that tree other than
potentially give it to him which I
didn't even know it was an option and
two I wanted to be able to have a
neighborly relationship and that's where
we're at that's where we're at today and
three you wanted to make some good clean
podcast and
tainment yeah I mean of course this
whole thing is just a big made-up story
that's what guys entertainment no it's
not at what point did you touch his
shoulder when he said I'm sorry for what
I said I was like hey man I get it I get
it
oh it was more fingertip tea yeah it's
like this was it grab I get it
it wasn't grabby it was just like hey
you don't even have to apologize I
totally get it we've all been there
but your shoulders you could have put
your arm around him I was a lot closer
to him than I am to you I mean we were
really like I may have actually had some
incidental contact throughout the entire
meeting oh wow like thigh the thigh
situation sure there was knee to knee
I'm sure there was Wow Wow unintentional
okay so what have we learned here we've
learned that lead with an apology follow
up with a shoulder grab and when in
doubt touch thighs no consensually
scratch that last part that was not
anything that I did and there was no
thigh touching knee touching and it was
knee to knee which is different than
hand to me very different well I'm
really really happy that it turned out
this way I'm I no way was hoping that
you'd get punched in the face that was
never gonna happen that could have
happened that day that could have
happened that day if I had to escalate
it but you know me I don't escalate yeah
you should have let me out of that yeah
I CV I don't escalate I I was about to
burst out of it I pacify like a banshee
yeah so Wow although what a fizzle you
wanted it to continue well I don't know
I mean I'm gonna bring him on here I bet
you I can rile him up again he's in he's
really into to whine and I'm gonna get
him some of that for Christmas so yeah
I'm just
yeah I'm just being neighborly man just
trying to set an example wine in the
left hand a handful of his shoulder in
the right touch his shoulder when I give
him the wine Wow okay but speaking of
shoulders I've touched your shoulder a
few few times and I've really enjoyed
the softness not only of your shoulder
muscle but just on the wonderful new
metal morning talked the good mythical
morning sweater which I was just telling
you boys sure didn't call it a sweat a
sweet advertising mythical dot store get
yourself a
good mythical sweatshirt if you it's one
of my favorite pieces of merch that
we've ever released because I just
listening and Creta credible incredibly
tasteful design if you're just listening
to my sweatshirt right now you can
probably tell that it's very silent I
don't even know what color I would call
that it's a it's not quite blue not
quite what is that it's not it's not
quite teal it's like it's it's a light
blue but it's got a little bit it's it's
just beautiful check it out guys
mythical dot store support internat
Ament and rep your boys rep your boy rep
your boys last Thanksgiving I'm going to
talking about a few weeks ago I'm
talking about a year and a few weeks ago
26 we went to a vacation to Kauai that's
in Hawaii net had never been to Hawaii
and we took our families and we all went
to Hawaii it was a great time a brain
quite I had a great time it rained a lot
and the whole time we were there you
were very you you you were up in arms
about the rain I mean cuz it's like I
mean that can really define my wife was
and that that that translated to me but
to your credit I mean even while we were
there you were like I wonder if you were
like I don't want to make this mistake
again this time next year we're gonna be
on vacation again and I appreciate the
fact that I didn't have to lift a finger
or a thought because you were like well
this is not it's not sunny it's not hot
enough Thanksgiving night we went to
like the big luau would like the the the
the Hawaiian pig we're eating all of
that stuff and then it's time for the
show and then I go to the bathroom this
is outdoors and so I went in to go to
the bathroom I come back out and and I
thought that there was an emergency
people were running every whichaway
tsunami and I realized it was a downpour
and by the time I got back to the family
nobody was there and people were like
handing out Poncho's it was a
cataclysmic downpour and soaked to the
bone was our Thanksgiving night got a
refund on the show but not on the food
which we
so then you're like thinking are the
other islands better if we do if we
would have gone there you know and we
kind of knew that Kauai was the rainiest
of all the islands like the one of the
rainiest places on earth however I will
say that the south side which they call
the dry side of Kauai typically does not
have a lot of rain in November but it
did it did and that kind of that kind of
put a it kind of made our vacation soggy
you know we're like ziplining and doing
some stuff with the you know with
everybody and then here comes another
downpour and it's frigid
yes cold rain cold rain and so in the
aftermath of that
Rhett's like man we should go to Mexico
mm-hmm there you are not gonna get
rained on and put up ir de or Tulum or
what's the other place really the West
Cabo though I don't know much about the
East Coast but you're not the west coast
in November he rained on Thanksgiving
and I'm like you're right I'm gonna do
that and then we start figuring out
where we're gonna go and we decided that
we're gonna have separate vacation well
you decided that yeah I will say that so
before you tell you throw me under the
bus I'm not throwing you okay
Oh what for how I did the switcheroo
look at the last minute which I which I
believe is I can explain but the next
point yeah the pie was ready I were
going to Mexico I was ready for a dual
family vacation again picked out a
resort for all of us in Mexico we
already and then I was like I think we
should just you know vacation separately
this year which oh it's fine with me too
I'm fine either way
yeah yeah and peace maker I give trees
to people yeah you know I know your your
feelings weren't hurt by that but I
think you you know we know each other
long enough to know that like me and
Christy - we're like sensitive to our to
our space and we we are of the families
we are much more opinionated and I will
I will own that
so like where you're like you're judging
things like the weather and is this is
this the vacation that you hoped it
would be for everybody we we are also
assessing lots of things and it's not
worth getting into because it's it's
mostly just things that like what you
know says I'm a picky eater I'm picky
about a lot of things this is true and
it you know in no way should I would
hope that you guys would take it
personally
I think the big clincher for me was a
week since that point we hadn't had any
any family vacation time and like as an
eel family and that's something that
mattered to us at that moment plus I
anticipated how much time we were gonna
be spending together even over weekends
that's true with the tour so I'm like I
think that I will want to be separate
from Rhett and I think that he's gonna
want to be separate from me even if you
wouldn't say it and you may not you may
not have thought that but I think it a
little like weekends apart is a healthy
thing like if we had to spend Saturday
and Sunday everyone completely agree
with that and that's what the tour did
so I I I broached the subject to you and
I'm like and I know that you picked a
place in Mexico that we were all gonna
go so I'm like you know what I don't
want to take the first pick we'll pick
us we'll pick a second resort we'll both
go to Mexico and this where it got a
little weird and I don't know if this
what went into your choice to go to
Hawaii but it was like well just go
we'll both be in Mexico but we'll be in
separate resorts well but before that I
think what really set this off was the
place that I had chosen when I looked at
the resort when I was making the
decision over the summer I was like oh
this is okay this is not this isn't bad
this is a pretty affordable place yeah
but then once we got around to actually
booking for Thanksgiving the price had
literally tripled the price per night
had tripled and we get two rooms
per family right and so it a hurtin
it'll put a hurt it was just suddenly
the place that I wanted to go not just
how much we paid for Hawaii yeah I could
not justify spending that much money and
so at that point we started looking at
other options in in Mexico and then but
those options were still pretty
expensive yeah so my whole thing was not
only that I want son but I was like but
Mexico's a shorter flight it's gonna be
overall less expensive and then we
started looking at these different
places and you ended up deciding well
both of the places we were looking at
we're all-inclusive and Jesse and I have
had not so great experiences with
all-inclusiveness
I'm I'm less picky than she is and so
I'm like okay maybe the food gets old
after a little bit but I'm fine with
that but I service may not be as good
and we had that same experience but
because I make the decisions about this
kind of thing let it usually just
because I'm really interested in doing
that and like yeah deciding on the
places I thought it's gonna come back on
me if we go down to this all-inclusive
place and she doesn't like it so I was
like well I mean look into Hawaii and
let me see if there's a place in Hawaii
that's supposed to not rain and that's
where I landed on the left side the left
side the west side of the Big Island
which is the driest part of all Hawaii
it's only supposed to rain like two days
in November on average and then I found
that the price was essentially the same
as if we were gonna go to Mexico so I
was like let's go back to Hawaii since
we're going by ourselves anyway let's do
that that's how we ended up going to
separate places and I think you know
we've talked a little bit about it and I
think the main thing that I didn't have
access to was a active volcano because I
know that you had the opportunity to go
to an active volcano and I want to hear
about that I think the thing I had I had
a great time in Mexico we did some
puerto vallarta we did some did a
ziplining day with the kids
Kristi does not she goes on zip she goes
if she did not go her and Lando stayed
behind because
it was too small they would not let him
do it so I took Lillian Lincoln and they
loved it and we had we had a great time
at this one place now I've actually done
a lot of ziplining because we did
zipline in Hawaii and except for the
rain that was amazing and that was with
like we did kayaking hiking ziplining
all in one day all in one trip this was
just a zipline anything I'll tell you
that the most amazing ziplining I've
ever done was in Northern California in
the the canopy of the redwood forest
they had built these do that
that was three that was two summers ago
when we went to Santa Cruz as a family
so there's a place outside of Santa Cruz
where you can zipline in the treetops
and it looks like the Ewok village looks
like Endor II walk town I think is what
it's called
so the this ziplining was not as great
as that that is the best as a blinding
he can't top it
but we still had a great time we did
another day where it was like some
snorkeling and we took a boat trip and
we had we had a lot of fun but I looked
everywhere for an active volcano that oh
those did not find one and then I I had
a couple of very negative experiences at
this at this resort really yeah and how
was the food oh I'm gonna tell you about
it now because what I want to I want to
I think your experience with the volcano
there might have been some I don't I
don't know I really want to hear how it
went so I'd like to get this negativity
out of the way very quickly because I'm
not gonna leave like a Trip Advisor this
is my version of a Trip Advisor you
don't really door to use you just take
what you don't give I really needed to
but I just I can't justify taking the
time to write a review I take about a
dog give the food was great it really
was it it was surprisingly great like
you can get food by the pool which was
really good and this is the best a great
experience when you're like by the pool
and you can order food and drinks and
you just hang it
out but the food he's not normally
fabulous and it was surprisingly
fabulous and then the restaurant also
pulled different kinds of restaurants
yeah the restaurants are really good too
so and that's why we chose this place
because it was reviewed very highly but
the thing they did not say was that over
the first three days they are going to
try everything in their power to get you
to go to a timeshare presentation
seminar meeting and I knew having never
done it I knew and we talked to some
other families there that had done it
before at other places and they will
they'll say it's 30 minutes due and then
they'll say we'll give you all these
discounts for zip line and all this
different stuff 40% off all you got to
do is eat breakfast with with one of our
representatives and then they'll take
you on a 30-minute tour of the place
that they want you to buy a condo in a
like a timeshare capacity and the fact
is it ends up lasting a couple of hours
how do they how do they but you didn't
go and I did not go but by the end of it
because I talked to some other people
there the resort by the end of it you've
got fathers and mothers almost ripping
their hair out to try to get out of this
situation without having to be pressured
into buying something and it makes me
more angry than it makes it well is it's
not I can think of things that would
make me more angry but it makes me livid
I went we'd go to breakfast how do they
come up to come up to you just blue when
we check in they're like and if you want
40% well at the airport even before I
left the airport a representative came
up and tried to trick me into saying
that they were the ones who were gonna
take me to the hotel and then for 20
minutes I end up talking to the guy even
though I knew it could happen and I was
trying to bypass it I still talk to the
guy for 20 minutes about all the stuff
that I could do the zip line and all
this stuff and then oh and by the way I
can give you a discount all you got to
do is meet me in the morning at your
hotel for a presentation I'm like no and
he's like well I'll give you this
discount I was like no I want to pay
full price I do not no matter what you
do this is what I said no matter what
you tell me I am
going to say no right now that's
literally what and he said and then he
said you know I'm actually trying to go
back to college yeah that's in the
manual and I knew just you two
he just flipped to the next page of his
script when you said that oh I've got an
over his I started to water a little bit
of course and then my face turned red
and my eye started to water a little bit
and land I was like grabbing at my arm
and like Daddy can we go and I'm like I
am I'm only going to say no to you this
is why and listen and then I get to I
get to the freaking reception and they
do it the same thing this is why I hate
multi-level marketing for the same rates
for the same reason because it's sales
under false pretense it's this I'm
trying to be your friend or I it's in
multi-level marketing is probably even
worse because it takes advantage of a
friendship then turns it into a
transactional relationship which is just
a horrible thing to do it's nice I know
a lot of people are into difficult
positions and they feel like they have
to do it but I just feel like there's a
better way I feel like there's a better
way but it's the same thing it's a
similar dynamic when it's just like I am
already paid I paid for this vacation
I'm here to enjoy it I'm not here to be
marketed to it was a yeah and it was a
resort that then next door was like a
sister resort with more of the
restaurants that we had access to and
when we walked you have to walk on the
beach to go around to get to it and when
I go on the beach for the first time a
guy comes up on the beach and starts his
strikes up conversation hello welcome to
the resort can I interest you and I'm
like no I do not want to meet you we and
then after that they I think they
finally caught wind of my scent and it
wasn't and it was stinky to them they
stayed away but I would go to breakfast
I wrote you off I would they they were
setting appointments for the rest of the
week with people and they and when I
would go to breakfast with my family
they would at every other table it would
be a family and a representative with a
nametag on like wining and dining him
for the same breakfast I had hmm I just
fell
so sorry for those people they didn't
even know they should be angry I didn't
get it like there was there was an old
couple that enjoyed the attention of
some super bubbly sales maybe there are
people who don't mind it and then do
appreciate the attention and actually
are interested in it I could have
murdered someone but it's obviously a
business that works because it exists
and I can't believe that the TripAdvisor
reviews of this place as mentioned that
via La Estancia screw you guys
and you're in your marketing you almost
ruined my freaking vacation and you know
what now feel strongly after they laid
off it was great it was great that the
food was great the people that we
interact with out there were great but
boy getting a little hot undercut cheer
me up with some volcano talk well this
is actually well let me I'll commiserate
a little bit with you I definitely was
not I nobody tried to sell me on a
timeshare but the conclusion I've come
to after going to Hawaii twice is that
and again I know I'm live in Los Angeles
I have access to like the best foods you
know some of the best food in the world
really I mean la just has so many
options I've become a food snob is what
I've become and you remember how Hawaii
was it was like we went to these nice
restaurants and they were like Hawaiian
restaurants which meant like fresh
seafood and some the third or fourth
night of that gets a little old and the
Big Island is a lot like Kauai in that
there's not I mean the whole west side
of the island is just like raw volcanic
rock I mean there's just some places
that it's just like a black landscape or
as far as the eye can see
most of it has already has gotten some
you know it's like I don't know how many
years ago this lava flow was but less
than a hundred and it's like black but
then there's some grass is like growing
in it but it's just like the newest
earth I've ever been on
super barren and just this in Crest
Coast is just this long
slope with nothing on it at all and then
there's these resorts along the coast
and so they like you go eat it like
another resort and then it'll be like a
little like shopping area that'll have
some restaurants but just I just the I
could have used more variety in the food
that was the one thing that I've kind of
like noted twice now about Hawaii I
think if you go to a Wahoo or Maui
there's some more food options if you're
into that kind of thing but we did make
the decision because of the lack of rain
which incidentally did not rain once at
the resort but we did travel to the east
side of the east side of the island
where it's very raining it did but of
course the other big thing that we were
excited about was seeing an active
volcano and so I was super super excited
about this I had a certain day set out
planned to do this I think we were gonna
do it on Wednesday which is right in the
middle of the vacation but on Tuesday
while snorkeling in the little Cove area
next to the resort which incidentally
was amazing we saw like multiple sea
turtles Wow like you'd go out and
there'd be like five sea turtles amongst
all this other fish and stuff too like
oh like could you reach out and touch
their shoulder like a neighbor you were
not supposed to get within ten feet of
them so let's just say hypothetically I
may have gotten in closer than ten feet
and I may have just for a moment pet the
back of one of them but that's just
hypothetical I didn't actually do that I
stayed ten feet away like they say you
should but it was absolutely phenomenal
and but then locking shepper narrow are
pretty far out like Turtles lawyers
gonna send you a letter and then Locke
says dad I got a cut on my leg you think
I should go back in and I was like yeah
you probably should you know but I
wasn't trying to instill panic I was
just yeah you could just cuz you're cut
he was thinking because sharks and
didn't even realize that that's
immediately what I just thought blood in
the water man so he's like turns out
what happened is he started freaking out
and then he's swimming back in
his mask comes off and then now he can't
see into the water and so he just holds
his mask and he's swimming like crazy
and he swims right into a rock oh and he
cuts his knee it was I wouldn't even
call it a cut it was like taking a chunk
like a divot out of his knees I didn't
know about this I continued to snorkel
with Shepherd we saw some more turtles
we came back in and then I'm like
where's Locke and I see the EMT like the
beach doctor it's got him sitting down
over there and he's like cleaning this
wound and I go over there and like what
happened Locke tells me the story that I
just told you and then he's like Locke's
like dude I was like do you think any
stitches because I was thinking like oh
man we gotta go to like a hospital this
is such a vacation downer and it guys
like oh no no no I cleaned it up and
just put this with this wrap on it you
know it'll fix it
what a timeshare yeah you know just
spend a couple of minutes with the
representative inside and that thing
will heal right up well but what did
what this did is first of all a this guy
should have told us to get stitches
because it still hasn't completely
healed
in fact since then I've been like
treating this wound and there was like
because it like took a chunk of the
flesh out but then left like this cover
of flesh on top of this hole oh it was a
full two weeks later that Locke calls me
when we're on tour and he's like dad
that piece of skin that was kind of
sitting on top of my wound I cut it with
scissors is that cool and I'm like ah he
asked before you did yeah
and I'm like well how does it feel he
was like oh it's butter so I was like
okay whatever but so it is kind of
healing up now but we should have
definitely gotten stitches but what this
the the net effect of this is that he
couldn't really bend his knee that great
he couldn't get in the water the rest of
the time oh no in the in the very next
day we had planned to go to the
volcanoes and like he didn't need to be
bending his knee that much so we pushed
the volcano trip to the very last day
which heading had a high wind forecast
so it takes like two hours to drive from
the resort to volcano
ye national volcanoes national park so
they call it and there is basically an
active volcano that looks more like a
giant crater like a huge crater that
you're like standing on the outside of
it does it I mean it it's a it gets a
cone like it goes up Rio cone oh it's
just it I think it looks flat I think
it's like collapsed or something okay
but basically you go up to this and it
feels like this giant crater that's
completely flat and then in the middle
of the giant crater like somebody
literally like came and took it like a
cookie cutter and just like took some
earth out but it kind of like locks neat
and then in the well it wasn't that
clean in the middle of that giant crater
there's another giant cookie cutter
circle and that's filled with lava now
you cannot see the lava well you can see
the glow of the lava at night but the
what the the lava level fluctuates and
sometimes it'll be you know a hundred
feet from the surface and sometimes
it'll be like 2,000 feet below or
whatever it just goes up and down but at
this point it was well below so you
could see it at night so I'd plane this
whole thing out and this is not is that
you getting to it or is that people
describing it you can't well you can
stand on the edge of the exterior crater
but you cannot go out into the other
crater it's against the law because
there's some noxious fumes that are
coming out of there and it can
incapacitate you and so for a while now
you haven't been able to get next to the
volcano unless you're like a trained
scientist with the proper equipment but
my whole plan was we're gonna go up
there there's a lot of really cool stuff
to see in the park like lava tubes and
steam vents and you take this you take
this road all the way down to the beach
and you see like places where this lava
flow happened and this year and right
next to this forest that all these cool
features but when I asked the person at
the well first of all a couple of couple
of shoutouts I'm gonna give that tie
into this story first thing we get to
the entrance to the gate and there's a
girl working there and are like a you
know National Park Ranger outfit and I
like hand her my 25 bucks to get into
the park and she's like wrecked
I'm like yes she's like I listen to ear
biscuits it's the first thing she said
she didn't say I love GMM she didn't say
I like buddy system she said I listen to
ear biscuits and I wish I could remember
her name I'm I was kind of shocked when
she told me and of course I was in a
line of cars so I didn't have time to
process it but shout-out to the girl who
let me in the gate of the Hawaii
National volcanic arc and thanks for
being at your biscuit ear but that
you're busy year 25 back no she didn't
know discounts I didn't expect it well
it's the government and I got to do it
but the ear biscuits shoutouts are going
to continue so I go to the main area the
visitor center because this is usually
don't happen right yeah yeah go to the
visitor center and I wait in this line
and he's no I mean nobody's listening
right now that's right there's me and
you yeah and that girl from the from the
park yeah and same we don't know her
name because she's the only one
listening no there's at least two so
then I go to a get in line because I
wanted to talk to them about the
possibility of seeing the lava flow and
I've met a guy at the hotel who
basically said oh no you can't see the
lava flow with with small kids it's like
it's like a eight mile hike and stuff
like that it changes from time to time
but right now it's like a huge hike
you're not gonna actually be able to see
live lava so don't forget that but you
you were like maybe no no as we talked
someone I had resigned myself to this
okay I wait in the line I hear the woman
basically consist our crane jerk
confirmed that and she's like now in
order to see the lava flow it's going to
be an 8 to 12 mile round trip hike
what and I'm like whoa dang I wasn't
even planning on being here all day so I
heard her say that to somebody else I
was just like okay guys we're not gonna
be able to see the lava we're gonna stay
here we're gonna see all this cool stuff
in the park and then at night we're
gonna stay and we're gonna like see the
lava from a distance it'll be cool but
we go to the first the first like cool
stop which is the steam vents which you
kind of get next to the crater and then
there's like these places right there on
the you know side of the road and
there's just steam coming up and I'm
standing there the wind
is incredible the wind is like blowing
like crazy like blowing you over almost
and then this park ranger kind of walks
up behind us and he's like Rhett and
Leigh hey man he's like he comes up he
says I listen to ear biscuits
you're not kidding I'm not making this
up another park ranger who listens to
ear biscuits
they're just eaten up ear biscuits left
and right at Hawaii Volcanoes National
Park man that's what they do there they
must be on the move and they got and I'd
like to listen to things and I said did
the girl at the front gate said that you
don't want to but you can't watch GMM
because you might walk into a steam you
got to be listening or a volcano and
I've got listening and I do remember I
do remember this guy's name because I
talked to him for a while his name is
pono and shout out to pono because pono
you changed my life man I'm about to
tell you how you changed my life
because what a pono change your life
because he said I share please show me a
timeshare yes exactly how did you know
that's where I was gonna screw you pono
so pono says lay off no I said after I
talked to him a while about the fact
that he listens to your biscuits indeed
he did the other person introduced him -
no I said the girl at the front gate
listens to your biscuits - and he didn't
say like yeah she's the one who told me
I think it was just like the look on his
face was like we all listen to air
biscuits I mean he didn't he didn't
explain himself okay so I you know
there's a big staff there so then I'm
like he's like so you guys just get here
I was like yeah we literally just came
through the gate this is our first stop
we're gonna be here all day I really
wanted to see the lava flow but yeah I
heard it's a real long hike he says oh
no you can see the lava flow and then
he's like he said they tend to
discourage that at the Visitor Center
because it is you know it's not actually
inside the park and it's a it's a little
bit of a trek to get there but you can
definitely see it he says what you got
to do is you got to go out of the park
you got to drive for an hour
oh and you go drive all the way out of
the park and then down to this little
town back down to the coast and then you
drive along the coast until the road
stops because lava has take
over-the-road what and there will be
several no not several dozens of
companies who will sell you a wrench you
a bike and then you guys came bike for
miles on this road and then you can walk
to the lava here's like it'll take you
half an hour like once you get you take
your hour to get down there
rent the bikes you can get a tandem bike
to put your youngest son on there and
then you can just ride your bikes right
up to this place and then you'll hike on
the lava for between half an hour and an
hour and you'll find some people looking
at lava it'll be great
you should be there approximately four
o'clock it'll be perfect well he kind of
made it sound like an Ironman
competition but you said yes I said
absolutely a Stickley we stuck around
the park for a little bit more that's
some sweet insider info yeah to see a
couple of the other things he's like you
definitely should see the lava tube and
you should go down so we did a couple of
those things and then we get in the car
we drive down there we get to the place
where you get the bikes we get the bikes
first of all they actually have a
shuttle that can take you like two miles
but I was like no we're at McLaughlin's
we're gonna do this let's ride the
fricking bikes it's just flat
I put Shepherd on the back of this
tandem bike it's one of those things
where it's it's not a two-man bike it's
a button normal bike that then has this
other like just wheel and handlebars
kind of seat handlebars and a wheel and
pedals behind half bike that kind of
like is behind it which made it kind of
like I was a donkey pulling a load were
you so what if you said lava came over
the road and you had that's where you
park and got the bike were you riding a
bike on lava yeah what really they
basically have a bike path misra made up
it is a road but as far as the eye can
see
it's just raw black volcanic rock that's
all it is black volcanic rock nothing
growing too fresh for that nothing
growing and how hot was it when you get
in the bike was it was the lot was there
anything no it's been I mean the Porsche
built a whole bike area well yeah but
that's right where that's right we're
the road
because that's like a lava flow from
years and years ago right so basically
what we do is we take our bikes it it
actually wasn't that easy but it took
half an hour to get to the flight four
mile mark going pretty fast and they
basically have created like this gravel
road on top of the volcanic rock so they
probably got some bulldozers out there
and just kind of like crushed it down
and then we get to this place where
everybody was getting off their bikes
and just starting to just walk and
they're like just walk towards the steam
so the so the road ended you could not
have ridden the bike no I could have but
they were like sometimes people get off
at the this mile marker sometimes people
get off at this mile marker and you
should just go to the like the third one
I think and then every and that's where
most people are getting to the lava flow
faster today like they tell you that at
the bike thing cuz I guess I only went
three miles so then we just start
walking and it's just walking over this
just Black Rock that almost like
crumbles some of it like crumbles under
your foot and some of it's really really
hard and this look it just looks like a
bunch of rock this kind of just and they
just hardened up because that's exactly
what happened now fart fart fart hard
and harden a lot of this lava is like
flowing kind of underneath the ground
but then kind of coming up to the
surface in a couple of places and then
historically it's just going into the
ocean you know basically creating the
island and so that's when you can see
those like dramatic pictures of like
lava flowing into the ocean and the
steam and that kind of thing like you
have to take like I had either a
helicopter or like a boat to see that
and that wasn't happening the day that I
was there they were like but it's a
surface flow you'll be able to see lava
we hiked for what felt like it had to be
an hour oh shepherd fell one time I mean
my family I'm surprised we survived
because my wife and I gotten so many
arguments because I wanted to get to the
freakin lava flow before the Sun went
down so I could see it in daylight and
it's sundown and she's like just
stopping and taking pictures like
literally like she walks like four steps
and it takes another picture and I'm
like it's just the same thing
over and over again you've got the
picture you're like saying that so we're
mad at each other she's way way behind
me she's just like go on then just go on
and I'm like we'll get lost are there
kids
there's no mothers there's no path
there's no path there's no there's no
way - there's no points of reference are
there don't die out here are there other
people that are hearing this argument
yeah yeah yeah yeah come they're coming
up they're like Rhett no I listen - no
one would hear arguments no one would
have come up to our family in the state
that we were in about half a mile into
this thing so then and then an hour of
hiking arguing about pictures and then
Shepard is like dolphin Shepard Falls
and then I go over to him he's bleeding
in like 17 places because this is
volcanic rock and he's bleeding from his
knee he's bleeding from his elbows he's
bleeding from his hand and he's not
crying he's just he skinned himself up
and he's just like we'll what are you
gonna do and they had given me this
first aid kit the bike people because I
guess they knew this was gonna happen
huh and so I like start putting
band-aids on him and stuff they gave you
a water band and then they gave me like
a first aid kit in my little pack and so
then let's go weeks keep walking I keep
stopping and letting Jessie take
pictures eventually we see this like
group of people when I get off your bike
make sure you and you fall make sure you
use the tourniquet here's the tourniquet
and here's the wasn't it wasn't that
serious but it could have been very
serious we get up to this group of
people and they're all looking down I'm
like those people look like they're
looking at lava mm-hmm you could see it
on their posture and as we began to walk
towards them as they came into view I
started noticing there was this immense
heat emitting from the rock that we were
on and then we got a little bit closer
and I touched the rock that when walking
on and it was hot like a hot pan like
couldn't keep my hand on it Oh like a
grill yeah and then I started noticing
in the cracks and the earth beneath me
he was glowing like the pits of hell
like big of a crack just like just small
little cracks like a little crack like
that and you look down into it and you
see just like red-hot glow
and then another you know dozen yards or
so and we arrived at the place and it's
just this there it is like there was
this I think I put this I think I
Instagram story this I know that's not
relevant now because this Instagram
story's gone but basically you've seen
videos like this before but it was
essentially just these big globs of lava
kind of really really really moving very
very slowly like people were getting up
like two feet from it and taking a
picture and it would like be moving like
this it wasn't like about to overtake
anybody it's the kind of thing that you
could easily get out of the way of it if
you're not a tree or a house were you
tempted to touch it no but I was tempted
to throw things at it and so was Shepard
and Shepard was like cut out the whole
rock out I kind of throw a rock at it
and then somebody else threw a rock at
it and it was amazing what happened
because they threw a rock at the molten
rock and it just bounced off the molten
rock because it's so dense it didn't
just like go into it like nope you know
it just like bounced off of it cuz it's
still rock but if you would have placed
the rock like whether if the rock
settled on the red-hot lava would it
have gone down into it like the ring and
Mordor I don't think so I honestly don't
think so I honestly think that if you
ran fast enough your foot would catch on
fire but your foot would not sink into
it because the density of this rock is
so much more than you you know I'm
saying you float on top of lava because
the rock is so dense you think about
peeing on it I would have if I there was
not a large gathering of people so you
not only thought about it you knew you
would have done it oh yeah I definitely
would have done it but what we did do is
we went to one of those molten hot
cracks and you know what water into it
if you peed on it the the heat from the
lava would travel up the stream and burn
your your Weiner that's not true that's
not how science works I will say one
thing though if I had it done that it
would make it hotter look it's peeing on
the lava would be like some violation of
some sacred Hawaiian understandings of
lava well that's a bigger point so I
think that would be a very very it would
be like peeing on the Hawaiian people
and their traditions so I did not want
even though I thought about it I
actually did not consider it but what I
ended up doing well is gonna say I think
you can pee on things in a loving way
but I'm not gonna say that and we're not
gonna explore that but we took some rad
pictures and we went we went to another
one it got dark and it was just like the
only thing that was glowing was the lava
are you afraid I mean yeah you've is a
pattern here of your your boys injuring
themselves every every way they were
gonna fall in this lava well Jesse's
taking pictures a lot of people saw the
pictures that you know I posted and
Jesse posted and there was lots of
comments like did you guys have a guy do
because this is that's really dangerous
and I was like I didn't think about that
but I have mandates I honestly think
that especially once it got dark even
before it got dark it's very very easy
to see where the lava is and again it's
molten rock it's not like an egg shell
that's hardened on top and then if you
step on the wrong place you're gonna go
through the ice all of a sudden and burn
yourself I know ice is a bad analogy but
you know saying it's not like an egg
we're this hot yoga underneath it that's
not what's happening at all so I don't
know anything about what I'm saying
right now I'm just using intuition but I
don't think that it's super super
dangerous because I don't think they
would let like dozens of just randos you
know random tourists go out there and
just start walking around with their
kids no one seemed alarmed when we were
all taking pictures really close to it
well the park person didn't want to tell
you about it but the person who was
selling you a bike ride did yeah so what
do they have to gain but then we had to
we had to go back and this is when we
had yeah this is when the family yeah
you can't stay in hell forever the
family almost felt completely apart on
the way back to the bikes because now
we're hiking in the dark and so what I
said from the beginning is I said okay
guys here's the plan daddy is gonna take
the lead daddy's gonna go first followed
by lock then Shepherd then mom hmm and
we're all gonna be in a single-file line
and I'm going to be finding the best
possible path over this rock because
it's crazy and we can't see
they lock in the dark I mean Locke and
Jesse had headlamps because they gave us
two headlamps oh that's good
Shepard had this little light that he
bought at the gift shop and then I had
my phone Oh what that's how we're that's
how we're lighting our way they gave you
two headlamps in there four of you yeah
they did not fully equip us but I look
back and they had already gotten your
money Mike and Jesse are holding the
headlamps in their hands guys put them
on and they're like we don't want to put
them on and then it began to dawn on me
just how individualistic my entire
family is and how everyone wants to do
things their own way and there's no way
they're gonna be in a single-file line
I can't tell you how many times I look
back in my little single-file line has
completely disintegrated they're all
over the place
everybody's choosing their own path and
everyone's arguing and then Jesse's like
you're going too fast and I'm like I'm
in that I'm literally going so slow you
cannot be slow so I'm going so slow that
now Shepherd in Locker passing me I'm
like you guys are missing a freaking
point oh you know what would have made
it better if I had brought my family
there I mean I'm just I don't I'm just
saying I mean I'm I'm glad to hear this
part of the story because I'd really
love to see that lava but I wouldn't we
would not have contributed positively to
that experience it would have been there
would have been a very similar dynamic
and it doesn't sound like something I
needed to be there for but then we have
finally eventually made it back there
was a couple of families who in fact
what it was I'm sitting there I'm having
one of my daddy talks and I'm like guys
you have got to listen to me I am
picking the good path and there's
another family coming up and the dad so
he's in he's in he's in front he's like
there are no good paths he like called
me out in front of my family and I'm and
and then so then the rest of the time
I'm like stay with me and locks like
there are no good paths he says quote
he's quoting this random dad and it's
why the guy just totally throw me under
the bus vote of confidence
we ventually make it back to the bikes
we make it back he was miserable too
wasn't he he seemed happy
his family seemed like they were
following him they were all everyone
seemed happy and compliant no one was
going slow no one was falling he seemed
like he had his family completely under
control
so unlike me who's the problem and so we
make it back to where we dropped the
bikes off and there is a thing a little
a place to get coffee and get some
coffee at this place and the girl
selling coffee says I listen to ear
biscuits now if she didn't say that but
she did say my sister is a big fan I was
like aveer biscuits and she was and no I
didn't say that she was a GMM fan and
then there was a place called the hotdog
the hotdogs lady they called her the
hotdog lady and this lady had should
have been lava dogs or something this
lady had this food cart down there they
had like 17 different types of hotdogs
that made it all better boar and elk and
venison and all kinds of things it was
like GMM basically it was like our meat
man somehow has made his way down there
and he's selling his weird meats they
cook it over lava no it's not that cool
but I had a hotdog and it tasted so good
because I'd been arguing with my family
and then we got back into the car and
had a debrief and everyone apologized
and we were a family once again mmm the
family that hikes together fights
together yeah this is really what
happened that's a good teacher yeah that
will work
the family that fights together hikes
nope the other way I said it
but shoutout to pono for giving me an
experience of a lifetime and almost
tearing my family apart the last parts
not your fault I mean it literally was
one of the coolest experiences of my
life seeing the earth being formed now
you just you can't you can't even
appreciate it I guess I'll do it next
year you should I'm gonna go to Mexico
can you but can you plan it for me
sure all right I'm gonna be arranged in
no time Cheers
all right yeah I'll need to look at
those pictures you still got him I think
they deleted most of them okay I'll have
to I have to imagine that was a shame it
was a vivid thing all right guys next
Nate we're gearing up for another
vacation it's called the holidays yeah
but it's going home to the to the fam
that's happening
mean well that's not that's not
immediate but that's happening at the
end of the year so gearing up for that
totally different experience than the
resort life but I'm looking forward to a
reunion with the loved ones and yeah
thanks for hanging with us and for for
taking the taking the hike to the
hotness which is another piping hot ear
biscuit in your ear hole
don't burn your ears talk at you next
week
[Music]